this is a chip it's the brains of
electronic devices
laptops smartphones tvs and certainly
the device you're watching this video on
right now
almost half of these chips are sold
globally by american firms like qualcomm
and intel but now china is racing to
change that
the country has added almost 30 billion
dollars into its own semiconductor
companies
like chinese manufacturer smick smeg is
china's hope to win this tech race with
the us
smick is one of many little-known
chinese tech companies that saw their
stocks rise earlier this year
as the trump administration announced a
number of moves to effectively shut
chinese tech giants including tick tock
and huawei
out of the u.s market huawei is
something that's very dangerous i mean
washington's attitude toward china
particularly when it comes to technology
is that the
two countries need to separate we could
wind up with
two different ecosystems when it comes
to technology
this separation process has been called
decoupling
so how are the us and china trying to
become more self-sufficient
and what does it mean for tech giants in
both countries
we cannot take the security risks of any
of those companies
including huawei which as you know we
put a halt to huawei
and the hugely popular video app tiktok
have both been accused of being
potential tools for chinese espionage
and have been labelled by the us as a
security threat
we want to see untrusted chinese apps
removed from us app stores
president trump has mentioned impending
action on tick tock
and for good reason both huawei and
tiktok vehemently denied those
allegations
and said they operate independently from
chinese government
this administration has broadened the
notion of what national security is
way beyond any other administration and
when it comes to china
they define national security as data
all chinese technology is suspect
according to this administration
as tiktok received threats of being
outright banned in the u.s
and the u.s government said huawei would
be barred from buying chips from the u.s
and
other countries investment from china
has almost ground to a halt
chinese investment in the us is down 90
some odd percent
the restrictions have also startled a
number of american companies
which have been lobbying hard against
the changes huawei
is a big client for corporations
including qualcomm and intel
the likes of microsoft bill gates and
alibaba's jack ma
have said the recent escalations are
counter-productive for both sides
american companies supply parts to
huawei that may all go away
all of it i mean the trump
administration's message to american
companies and european companies that
want to do business
in china is don't do it come to the us
so how is china responding
beijing announced it would no longer
allow its own artificial intelligence
tech
think facial recognition and data
processing to be exported without new
licenses
beijing also said it wanted to launch
its own new set of global data rules
while washington and beijing are
fighting on a number of fronts from hong
kong to taiwan and the south china sea
tech has emerged as a strategic priority
that's where companies like smick come
in china has had a long-standing desire
to reduce chinese companies dependence
on foreign supply however it's really
not
until the trump's trade war that the
chinese leadership
realized that this is really serious we
really need to
put our act together now china launched
its own version of the nasdaq last year
the star market
and stocks there have soared it reflects
how much investors think companies can
benefit from the country's quest for
self-reliance
jinping there's a new slogan it's called
domestic circulation
this esoteric student means that china
going forward is going to prioritize
its own companies its own markets and
chinese consumption
chips are particularly important china
is the world's biggest consumer of chips
it spends more on chips than it does on
oil and imported
300 billion dollars worth of chips last
year
policy makers are using smick as a role
model for other companies with similar
ambitions
they're basically telling those
companies we're willing to invest in you
we're willing to help you but as long as
you
adhere to the policy agenda beijing is
already touting a number of successes
china's economy is forecast to be the
only major economy to grow this year
and that's benefiting its tech giants
huawei
which is already a global champion in 5g
technology
became the number one smartphone seller
in july
mostly thanks to its domestic market
where it sells over 70
of its phones but ending its reliance on
us technology
remains complicated you have a lot of
really smart engineers and scientists on
both sides of the pacific
if they are not working together that
will clearly [ __ ]
you know innovation huawei announced in
2019 that it can produce a phone without
us
chips still those substitute parts are
themselves made with american technology
and tools
and the administration has taken steps
to close the loophole
and if u.s regulation doesn't allow
huawei to buy key components made with
u.s tech
huawei may simply not be able to produce
its hardware
analysts estimate that huawei's
stockpile of u.s components
will only last one or two years huawei
has declined to comment on its inventory
huawei's situation is seen as a
confirmation that despite
heavy investment chinese chip companies
like smick
are still lagging behind whilst mick has
said it aims to accelerate the
development of its own chip tech
for now the company still relies on a
lot of u.s technology
and as the trump administration said it
was considering placing restrictions on
the semiconductor company
its shares tumbled china is said to be
about four years behind the us
and taiwan china has been here before it
has been trying to catch up with the u.s
for decades
and it's not the first time it has
invested so heavily in semiconductor
industry
however it still has a huge gap to feel
and now time is running short and the us
is also making moves
legislation is making its way through
the u.s senate that could pump an
additional 37 billion dollars
into american semiconductor
manufacturing and research and
development
and whether or not trump is re-elected
u.s actions aren't likely to stop
i don't think the a biden administration
would take a fundamentally different
view toward china china would still be
the number one competitor there would
still be issues
you know on human rights national
security technology
no matter who's next in the white house
this kind of
inward turning policy china has is here
to stay
china's leadership realizes the u.s is
no longer a reliable partner
so after years of escalating tensions
between the u.s and china
the decoupling of their tech industries
will now likely continue
i mean what the us at the moment is
doing is is saying to the rest of the
world
choose you know you're going to go with
us you're gonna go with them